affordability needs to improve a little
bit here we're too pressurized we're at
the very upper bounds of History right
now in terms of affordability to buy at
a home and that can come down through
three mechanisms the first mechanism is
[Music]
all right guys bang bang I've got Lance
here with me I wanted to do a deep dive
conversation on the housing market one
of the main reasons for that is because
housing makes up a massive percentage of
the CPI and so Lance I thought a great
place to start is why does housing make
up so much of that CPI calculation and
how do you think about the accuracy
maybe of the different price changes
year over year as part of the CPI
methodology for housing specifically
yeah I think with housing uh we're now
starting to see the FED uh consider
changing how it does housing CPI just
because of the incredible lag that's
there but I think a better place to kind
of get that rolling and that in kind of
better understand
how the FED messed up here is to look
back at what happened to housing during
the pandemic and this pandemic housing
boom which essentially started right off
the bat you know even before the
lockdowns were lifted and we still had
jobless rates at in the double digits
housing started going uh and what
happened there that got it rolling is
that you know this freedom to work from
anywhere and also being cramped up and
not being at the office increased demand
for space and at the same time that
historically low mortgage rates made it
to where almost all of the properties or
most of the properties on the Market
would cash flow for investors if you
bought something and then especially
once rents started rolling you were you
were in the green right uh and so it
created an investor rush it created a
rush from demand from these people who
wanted more space and could suddenly
work from anywhere and they had a
historically low mortgage rates
and what was happening is that the CPI
numbers were not starting to pick all of
this up and that even when we did that
third stimulus package at the time we
still didn't quite understand how much
uh housing CPI and housing inflation was
already rolling at the PO at the time if
they had actually understood at the
moment that housing home prices were
already up almost 20 percent and that
that you know was going to actually
continue to put upward pressure for
quite some time on inflation maybe they
would have not went as ambitious with
the fiscal spending side and as you
watched 2021 uh
it's bewildering how did the FED
continue to keep rates so low when three
percent mortgage rates were just feeding
this beast and inflation was just
running and the housing market and by
Spring 2022 we were up 42 nationally for
home prices and what we've seen in the
months since the Federal Reserve started
to rake uh increase uh the federal funds
rate and move into quantitative
tightening as we've seen a series of fed
papers come out and try to better
understand this housing boom and a few
things we found is that one the FED has
admitted that the pandemic housing boom
was driven by a demand demand boom not
by tight Supply uh they they have found
that the home construction would have
needed to increase 300 percent just to
match the amount of demand that was out
there and and here's the thing about
this demand it's hard to pick up in like
home sales data and mortgage purchase
applications because not all of the
demand was satisfied right like there
was only so much Supply so many homes
that people could buy the real
measurement of demand is the number of
people who were bidding on these homes
and it was an astronomical number of
investors and uh buyers out there trying
to get these homes during the pandemic
housing boom and so the FED has admitted
that demand drove it that's part one two
another fed paper came out and found
that 39 of non-housing inflation was
driven by the housing boom and the
run-up in home prices and so how does
that work well when home prices rise it
can create a wealth effect and when home
prices rise 42 percent in some markets
like Phoenix and Boise 60 70 percent it
creates a big wealth effect and that is
most acutely felt on uh you know older
Americans who have more housing wealth
and so for some of them uh you know that
increased their spending uh you know
they weren't afraid to hold back on
splurges and that just fed into an
inflation and another part of it is it
led to a big increase in retirements uh
these Boomers who were like you know
what I'm a couple years away from
retirement but you know these investment
properties I own they've went up so much
I'm going to sell I'm going to go into
retirement and that has restricted labor
even more so and so this housing boom
has fed into other facets of the economy
and another part of it is also in the
supply chain uh you know this housing
boom which also created a bit of a
construction boom
um and you know Builders just could not
satisfy the demand there just was not
enough Supply and they didn't have
enough labor and they just couldn't ramp
up fast enough but it overwhelmed the
supply chain all of the demand for the
goods as this housing boom was going on
keep in mind that a lot of people were
moving out of cities like San Francisco
and New York and la and to places like
Boise and Phoenix and if you live in New
York and you're in a you know 500 square
foot apartment you don't have a lot of
[__] and so when you move to a place
like you know let's say Tampa and you
buy a single family home three four
bedrooms you're gonna need to buy a lot
of stuff and so that huge migr and it
wasn't necessarily huge but it was so
quick that it overwhelmed the supply
chain and it fed into inflation more so
so one of the things that's fascinating
to me is this idea of the housing boom
driving this like wealth creation in
that is this because people have either
investment properties that they are
selling or even maybe their primary home
and they're selling and they're
capturing some sort of financial gain
and that kind of just goes in their bank
account now they have this extra money
or is it more things like kind of cash
out refi's or refinancing uh of their
homes at the lower uh mortgage rates and
the value is going on up and so they're
able to actually capture some of that
liquidity like how much of this is
liquidity that's being captured in the
real estate market versus it may just be
kind of on paper they're actually
getting wealthier and therefore that
gives them more confidence to spend
other money but it's not necessarily net
new money that they captured from their
actual real estate uh or kind of home
values yeah so a part of the wealth
effect is actually broader than housing
it's also crypto stocks everything
everything was moving up so fast and
everybody you know felt richer right
um and so that feeds into the wealth
effect and that feeds into people's
spending uh but but when housing is
running like that and and mortgage rates
are low for investors that makes it very
easy to continue to build their
portfolios really fast and when rents
are running up like they were
um you know and these properties are
cash flowing and you can refinance your
other properties it you know it really
feeds into that frenzy that we sell and
so yeah there was a huge liquidity
bubble that was rolling through the
economy
how much is the expectation that we will
see rents come back down like one of the
things with inflation that I always
point out is that inflation measures
year-over-year change uh but if the
local grocery store or uh you know fast
food joint raises prices it is very
unlikely that they are now going to go
back and slash them you know 10 20
percent and bring them back down uh is
the same thing true when it comes to
housing or rents or do we expect to
actually get some sort of kind of Market
correction and and find some equilibrium
that may be between you know
pre-pandemic levels and then ultimately
those pandemic highs
yeah when it comes to price deflation
housing is one of the places that it's
the stickiest right
um and you know between 2006 or sorry
between 19 like 45
and
2007 home crisis essentially didn't fall
you know there was a brief 2.2 percent
decline in the early 90s but really not
much uh you know and it actually fed
into a religion at the time uh of the
housing bubble which is that home prices
didn't fall so it was risk-free
um of course we learned after the
rollover uh between 2007 and 2012 when
U.S home crisis fell 26 percent the U.S
home prices can fall and as we fast
forward to this episode uh we have seen
uh home prices come down a bit from the
peak uh from June 2022 to November 2022
U.S home prices have fallen 2 2.5
percent if we stop there you know that's
not really much uh but if it were to
continue to go and you know like hit
some of the numbers like Bank of America
thanks uh which is closer to like a 10
Peak the trough drop that could have an
impact especially on home prices
um and especially in some of these
overheated markets like Phoenix Boise
Austin uh you know that would be a
sizable drop from the top uh when when
it comes to rents uh you know rent
deflation is very rare on a
year-over-year basis and even if it were
to happen
um it's not necessarily that people
people would feel it in their own rent
it
um yeah rent deflation's rare although
there are some people calling for some
mild Corrections for rents in places
like Phoenix
the interest rates or the FED funds rate
impact mortgages which then impact the
demand for new builds or purchasing of
homes it feels like every day I'm
reading whether it's on Fortune CNBC
Bloomberg Wall Street Journal just go
through all the financial media someone
is writing an article saying mortgages
are up or down based on interest rates
being up or down uh is it that simple
it's just like if the rates go down more
people want to go and borrow if they go
up they don't or are there other factors
that people should be aware of and
paying attention to the the house the
housing market is the most rate
sensitive sector of the economy and when
the Federal Reserve moves into its
fastest rate hiking cycle in the past
like 40 years it's going to have an
acute effect on housing and so we saw
home sales drop at a pace that actually
exceeded the 2006 drop in last in 2022
it was a huge drop in home sales uh at
the pace and we've since started to see
that slow down started to see that
bottom out we can see that in the
leading data like mortgage purchase
applications but yes where mortgage
rates go it's going to have an impact on
the housing market now the thing about
mortgage rates is they're a long-term
rate so when the FED is moving up
federal funds rate it's not like the uh
you know mortgage rates and the 10-year
yield are going to move up in sync with
it but the expectation for where future
rates will go where there's few Mutual
federal funds rates will go helps to
helps the financial markets to price
long-term rates like the 10-year and
like mortgage rates and so right now
what we've seen is we've started to see
some data signal that the economy could
be heating up a little more and we could
have a little more inflation and what
that means is the federal the Federal
Reserve would hold short-term rates the
federal funds rate up longer not
necessarily go higher maybe they would
but but they would at least hold longer
and that sends mortgage rates up as the
market prices in those future the future
uh rate uh trajectory so Neil Kashkari
uh one of the uh fed officials he said
almost exactly this right he said look
if there's any sign of life in the
housing market uh that makes our job
harder and I saw that you were writing
about this when you see something like
that how much of the federal reserve's
decision making is looking at the
housing market versus labor inflation
kind of other data points right do you
think that it is a major component or is
it just one of many data points that
they take into consideration in their
decisions around that monetary policy
yeah it's a core sector and it's a core
sector because they have so much control
over it and we've seen this now uh I
mean in a very short window uh when the
Federal Reserve went down to zero
percent interest rates uh it you know in
March and April 2020 when the pandemic
hit and then went in a massive
quantitative uh buying spray we saw
housing start to Boom now work from home
was also playing out in these other
factors but housing was running when
unemployment was at double digits
um and now when the economy you know we
have like a three percent unemployment
rate and mortgage purchase applications
are at the some of the lowest levels
we've seen over the past 20 years right
now
and that's in a very hot job market so
you know they have a lot of control over
housing and they pay very close
attention to it and if whole if home
prices were actually start to you know
get some upward momentum I think that
would really raise eyebrows at the FED
uh that's not what they would want right
now they want this to cool down they
want rent housing inflation to cool down
and to help to bring overall inflation
down and also be a transmission vehicle
into the rest of the economy so you slow
housing down and that can feed over into
the rest of the economy what's
interesting about this is I saw that you
were tweeting the uh seasonally adjusted
mortgage purchase applications are down
42 percent year over year which would
suggest that that is a major major fall
now of course we saw them run up in 2020
but when you zoomed out and you look at
what was those 2020 and 2021 levels
compared to the housing boom right
before the global financial crisis they
don't even register like it's like half
of what it was then is it any sort of
like base effect or anything to consider
in terms of like yes it got hot in 2020
and 2021 but it didn't actually get
anywhere near as hot as we saw before
that major correction of the global
financial crisis and so our expectations
should not be a 20 30 correction it
should be something much more measured
because really the good times they were
good prices were going up but things
like mortgage purchase applications
never got out of hand like they had back
in the mid-2000s hey guys what's going
on I hope that you're enjoying this
conversation but I wanted to interrupt
for a quick second and tell you about a
brand new conference that I'm hosting on
March 4th at the Miami Beach Convention
Center the event is called lyceum Miami
and tickets are completely free for
anyone who wants to come I'm bringing
together many of the most popular guests
from the podcast over the last couple of
years some of the guest speakers that
we've already announced are people like
Vivek ramashwamy from strive asset
management or Delian and Mike Solana
from Founders fund Chris Williamson from
the modern wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez
from contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian ogrenmeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceumiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there alright
let's get back into this conversation
well so here's here's what I would say
to compare the pandemic housing boom to
the 2000s pan uh 2000s housing boom
they're very different stories uh
what what they share in similarity is
the affordability Factor right now it is
actually more unaffordable uh to buy a
home in terms of debt to income than it
was at the top of the 2006 housing
bubble uh which is kind of which is an
amazing uh stat and that also speaks to
why housing has slowed down so much here
right now is because affordability is
pressurized to a historic degree and
that'll happen when home prices jump up
nationally 42 in two years and mortgage
rate Spike from uh two three percent up
to you know six percent
um but where the story kind of deviates
is that that last run up was really
fueled by a tremendous tremendous amount
of bad loans uh you know the subprime
crisis uh where they were just throwing
out these loans to people who couldn't
afford them and then uh it also Builders
were got got over their skis back in the
2000s they were building way more homes
than they should have and so as the
housing market hit that top in terms of
affordability and sales started to come
down cracks started to form in 2006
2007. uh all of the overbuilding led to
a supplied Lut
um as the economy started to weaken and
the unemployment rate Rose a lot of
those bad loan or a lot of those
subprime mortgages went bad and fueled a
foreclosure crisis and so when you
already had a supply glut and then you
have all those foreclosures that just
puts even more downward pressure on home
prices this story is different where in
the pandemic housing boom the boom and
the run-up in prices was actually driven
in a large part by higher income
individuals a lot of folks who were in
cities like LA and New York who couldn't
necessarily afford to buy in those
markets or they chose not to because it
didn't make a lot of sense because the
mortgages were so much more than rents
and they kind of they fled out of the
Cities into the excerbs into vacation
towns into those Western boom towns and
down to Miami and drove up home prices
so the story is a bit different and this
time inventory levels are just so tight
it's different but we can still have a
correction and we are seeing that out in
overheated Western markets like Phoenix
like Boise San Francisco how bad is the
housing shortage I've read a bunch of
different data points on this some
people try to say it's the equivalent of
the total number of homes in Miami uh or
or kind of other ways to really
highlight this but when you think about
housing shortage how would you describe
the severity of that problem
yeah I I've Tracked Down calculations by
about six different firms uh and they
range from like Freddie Mac thinking we
have like a three or four million a home
shortage in the United States to like
Moody's and John Burns real estate
consulting which are more like 1.6
million 1.7 million and zonda's kind of
like right there too and uh you know
it's some number
um but you know the researchers aren't
quite sure and for perspective in a
typical Year we're building like 1.5 1.4
you know during the pandemic I know
housing starts got up to 1.8
um so about one year's worth of Home
production is what you know is kind of a
closer General consensus among a lot of
these researchers and that number Rose
during the pandemic because there was an
acceleration in household formation and
what I mean by that is a lot of people
who were roommating together or maybe
they were living with their parents and
this pandemic boom occurred where there
was you know a lot more money to be made
in the job market there was a lot of big
offers uh their assets stocks crypto
housing were moving up and uh that
helped to fuel things but also people
just wanted more space and so a lot of
roommates were decoupling where they
were like you know what I'm working from
home I don't want to see you every day
I'm out and they got their own place and
uh so there was a lot of that going on
and that acceleration in household
formation and uh you know you know we
can't increase Home Supply very quickly
and so that increased the uh structural
shortage
from a shortage standpoint um if you
talk to somebody in San Francisco as an
example many people will point to
regulation and the inability to build
affordable housing on like a government
problem or a permitting problem uh if
you talk in other markets they may say
hey yes you can get the permit but it
takes a long time how much of the
shortage is not like market demand
um or kind of Market structure stuff
it's more so literally just permitting
problems either you can't get them or
they just take a really long time
yeah I think there's a lot of factors
the National homebuilder Association you
know definitely plays up the the
permitting part of it there's also the
fact that you know uh people have the
power to vote and you know if you don't
and Zoning can be controlled and if
people don't want a lot of high-rises
coming in or certain types of
multi-family housing uh you know they
can fight against that stuff uh but I
think here is a good point to be made
about this story right now and why it's
so complex I think anybody would agree
that San Francisco has a housing
shortage anybody would agree to that
right I think that's right
but right now home prices in San
Francisco among all the major markets
are down the most from the peak and it's
already a race 17 percentage points of
its pandemic housing boom growth
and so there's a huge structural
shortage in San Francisco perhaps the
biggest in the country but home prices
there have come down the most among all
the major markets so what's going on
well things overheated and you can have
prices drop even if an asset is if
there's a shortage of an asset if if
there's an overheating and so I I think
that's a part of why this housing story
kind of breaks people's minds because
they're like well prices can't come down
unless there's you know an oversupply
well it's like well not necessarily uh
it can happen and it's actually
happening the most and the places with
some of the biggest shortages which is
kind of ironic so one of the pieces of
information that gets scrutinized the
most uh and I get people writing to me
every single day is this idea of the CPI
calculation itself and obviously we
mentioned that shelter makes up I think
it's somewhere around 33 or so of it
um when you look at shelter across the
pandemic both in kind of the upswing and
now in the downswing the numbers that
were being reported by the BLS were much
lower than apartment.com or Zillow or
name your kind of private company and I
think why a lot of people had questions
about this was the BLS from a
methodology standpoint in some cases
they're like literally calling and
saying like hey what was your rent last
year what is it this year right and kind
of doing much more archaic type uh um
you know data collection and
synthesization
Zillow or a loop net or an apartment.com
or one of these websites they have you
know in some cases tens of millions of
data points around the country and
they're watching on a day-to-day basis
both price changes in terms of the ask
but also where those are clearing and so
when you evaluate the housing market how
much weight do you put on the BLS and
kind of the official shelter mechanism
or a measurement versus some of these
websites that may be reporting would
appear to be much higher numbers uh both
in the good times and bad times
yeah I I think there are serious flaws
with how the FED uh does uh it's
reporting on housing inflation
um and I I think they've realized that
and they're going to have to get better
at reading the data you know how housing
CPI has done is it's rent and then it's
rental equivalence which is like owner's
equivalent rent of their residence uh
which is like calling people and asking
you know how much do you think you could
rent your home for which is
kind of crazy
um in my opinion I don't know but look
back at when the the last stimulus
package was passed what was it 2.2
trillion at the time housing CPI was 2
percent
home prices that month were up on a
year-over-year basis like 16 15 16
percent
it it and there's a huge lag into the
CPI and and and housing is just a huge
leading sector I think just the way that
we track inflation the way the media
talks about it is definitely flawed I I
would hope the way that the Central Bank
does it I hope they understand uh how it
actually works and are looking at the
leading indicators uh but you know the
story of inflation was occurring long
before it was in the headlines
another piece of this story that I found
fascinating is I was talking to somebody
who is a luxury homebuilder and what he
said to me at one point during the
pandemic he goes we we've kind of gotten
pencils down we've stopped uh taking on
any new clients and I said oh it's that
good and he said partly but he goes also
we can't predict the prices of many of
the inputs for the home so there's some
easy things like the price of Lumbers
exploding and so we don't know what it's
going to be in three or six months and
so it's hard for us to price out a home
if we have kind of this variable we
can't predict but also we're having
trouble with the supply chains in terms
of getting windows or other types of
components of the home when you see that
stuff happening is there a way to
evaluate the impact of starting stopping
supply chain disruptions the price of
the different Commodities exploding like
how much of that is affecting the actual
changes in prices of homes or is it just
too complex and we've got to kind of
throw our hands up and say hey look
economies or economies they're very
complex machines and like we shouldn't
try to actually understand these various
nuances that may just be impossible to
measure
I think if we take a step back and we
look at this pandemic economy it's a
story of shocks of demand shocks where
you know we and Supply shocks uh you
know we grinded the economy to a whole
uh we restarted things in different
sectors very quickly you know when the
vaccines rolled out travel really took
off fast we then had one of the quickest
rate hiking Cycles which completely
grounded housing transaction activity
way down by the end of the year to you
know decade lows and uh you know this
economy it's just it's out of sync still
and I and I you know we you look at the
headlines and you look at these macro
economists they still don't know where
things are exactly headed you know
everything you know it ranges right now
from We're teetering on recession
to we're gonna have a soft Landing to
inflation is going to overheat again and
it's unpredictable and I can understand
how some businesses uh you know have a
hard time making decisions in that type
of uh macro environment where even the
experts are not just they don't it's not
that they're not close to a consensus
they're a polar opposite ends of the
spectrum and it's not just one or two
spectrums there's like three different
directions here
um and it'll be interesting to see how
things continue to uh move forward and
where we head next what is the impact
been on various house related stocks
right so whether they are home builders
they are some sort of supplier of home
builders uh maybe even some of like the
real estate businesses that are publicly
traded any insights there in terms of
how this like big swing and now what
appears to be some deflation uh has
impacted many of those stocks yeah if
you're going to take all of the real
estate stocks and try to put them into a
bucket it and look at them it's not
going to make a lot of sense uh because
you look at the Builder stocks and
relative to the you know the S P 500 and
some different stocks in the economy
they've done fairly well despite the
fact that you know we've seen mortgage
purchase applications fall 43 year over
year but then you take some of the
companies like Zillow Redfin open door
which all had I buyer businesses and
they've really went down uh open door at
the height was 34 their stock and they
became a Fortune 500 company they're
trading at two dollars now open door and
what happened for them is that they were
buying up these homes they were an eye
buyer uh you know and and they were
really heavy and a lot of these
overheated markets like Phoenix and Las
Vegas and once the market rolled over
and prices started to correct they were
a bag holder and they had to sell these
homes and so Glenn Kellman the CEO of
Redfin told me that you know they you
know had a commitment to their investors
and that they were going to do whatever
happens uh you know whatever it takes to
move the homes essentially and so every
two weeks in those markets they were
pricing things down two percent and so
not only were they taking big losses but
they were accelerating the corrections
in markets like Phoenix like Las Vegas
um and uh and we're still seeing that
play out Open Door still has a lot of
homes in Phoenix I think it's around
800. uh homes and they're still dropping
prices and it'll be interesting to kind
of see how that plays out but in real
estate and the stocks it's a little bit
all over the place uh and so some of the
eye buyers are in trouble some of the
digital platforms and more trouble but
the builders who had a really incredible
margins during the pandemic housing boom
don't let them tell you that Lumber was
making it to where they couldn't make
money they were making a lot of money
these were the best margins they've had
uh that I can see on the data and so
right now they've just given up on some
of the margins they've come down in
price they're doing mortgage rate buy
Downs where if like let's say it's a six
percent mortgage rate right now they can
buy you down and buy points on it to
where you get like a 4.2 4.5 percent
mortgage rate that's going to eat into
their margins but they can do it because
their margins were so flush and for them
also the builders uh you know there is
this structural shortage of homes so in
theory they should do uh a lot better
than some of these other real estate
companies and and the the one that's
been the most effective of course is
anyone on the mortgage side uh because
not only are mortgage purchase
applications down 43 year-over-year
refinances are down like 80 90 the
refinances are just done right now uh
you know there was a huge boom when
mortgage rates were two three percent
but now that we're uh uh over you know
we're at 6.6 percent today it just
doesn't make a lot of sense for a lot of
people to refinance is there a
bifurcation between the luxury Market
um in housing and kind of everything
else do you see different behaviors or
kind of different impact on prices
between those two markets yeah right now
I would call this housing correction and
the housing downturn I would call it a
bifurcated downturn and a bifurcated
correction you look at a market like
Chicago
and according to case Schiller they're
not even down one percent you look at
San Francisco they're down double digits
and what we've seen happen is we have it
bifurcated by the markets that Warren is
overheated and then the ones that were
the ones that were correcting more but
also
it at the lower end and the most the uh
you know the lowest priced homes the
lowest tier pricing they have not seen
prices drop as much because if rents are
so high and that's really lighting a a
fire under entry-level buyer speed and
they're still having to go out whereas
at the higher end we're we're seeing a
bit more of a correction and it makes
sense you know higher income individuals
they've seen their stocks come down uh
you know they don't have to buy and so
we've seen more uh you know weakness
there than we have at the entry level
and of course other markets like
vacation markets and further out into
the excerbs and places like that have
also seen bigger Corrections in many
markets what about the major Metro
rental uh kind of environment so New
York uh is the one I'm probably most
familiar with where uh during the
pandemic tons of people fled uh prices
came down significantly
um it seemed like uh they were going to
stay down there was talk of uh you know
New York's dead all the normal stuff you
would expect but it appears to be coming
back and I think now New York rents are
either at or near all-time highs what
has been going on uh there like
specifically in these major metros yeah
I think some of it is uh you know some
of those places were due for a bit of a
rebound as in some of the employers
started to bring people back to the
offices and New York's a little lucky
where they're more heavy finance and
those employers have been more willing
uh you know or to bring people back you
know you look at like Goldman Sachs and
so I think that's helping help to
strengthen not only their rental market
but also their housing market relative
to the rest of the country as we go
through this correction
and when you see uh the housing market
going through this correction what gets
us out the other side is it just fed uh
and kind of them you know providing
relief or are there other things that
you're looking at that potentially could
uh allow for you know a muting of the
correction but also some sort of
recovery
yeah I think when it comes to the
correction and I don't want to make too
many predictions but I I could go off of
what other major real estate firms are
thinking right now which is that
affordability needs to improve a little
bit here we're too pressurized we're at
the very upper bounds of History right
now in terms of affordability to buy at
a home and that can come down through
three mechanisms the first mechanism is
that incomes rise and we are seeing
incomes rise but it's nowhere near the
rate that home prices have went up uh
but income Rising here could
depressurize this a little bit the
second one is if mortgage rates were to
come down more this is the one that
could really move the needle the fastest
and we did see as mortgage rates came
down from like 7.3 percent in November
to 5.99 in early February we did see
some depressurized uh affordability and
some people moving back into the market
but now mortgage rates went back to six
six if they were come to come back down
further again or go go back even to 5.99
that would help and the third one is
home prices and so the longer that the
other two take to play out in comes
rising and mortgage rates falling the
more that we see this third lever pulled
which is prices and we have seen a port
a little bit we've deflated 2.5 percent
nationally between June uh 2022 and
November 2022 on a seasonally just a
basis but as it if it takes longer that
third lever will continue to be pulled a
little bit I believe
another question I have is around this
30-year fixed mortgage you mentioned
it's up over six percent how does that
relate historically like is that a near
all-time high what would it has been the
highs and how does that kind of uh look
when you just zoom out a little bit
yeah so as mortgage rates went up to
five percent and then uh made a b line
for six percent a lot of people on
Twitter especially older Americans were
like hey six percent whatever that is
not expensive historically you know we
had 18 mortgage rates in 1981 but you
have to look at mortgage rates with
prices and with incomes and when you
take everything into account this is one
of the mo least affordable housing
markets ever in American history it
wasn't when home prices went up 42 in
Spring 2022 but once you added the
mortgage rate Spike on top of it once
mortgage rates doubled we went all the
way up into the top of the historical
bounds so a six percent mortgage rate
today when accounting for prices and
winning accounting for incomes is
comparable to a you know a 12 13 14
mortgage rate back in the 80s
my last question for you uh or kind of
last topic I want to discuss is this
whole idea of the real estate market for
investors and I think what's been
fascinating is
um we've seen an explosion of like the
short-term rentals and kind of airbnbs
and all this especially among young
people who are like I'm gonna buy this
single family home and I'm going to rent
it out or whatever
um any insights there that you've seen
over the last two to three years around
uh the investment side of the real
estate market have there been kind of a
mirrored approach of the boom and bus
cycle or is it maybe bucking the trend
and actually investors are having a
different experience
um than uh than people who are just
using it for primary uh kind of homes
yeah so we've seen investor activity
rage during the pain during the pandemic
housing boom uh people going out and
trying to get short-term rentals trying
to build uh their you know portfolio of
homes they own if their landlord uh
we've seen more flipper activity
actually flipper activity got as high as
it did during the 2005-2006 Peaks uh
during the pandemic
um and we've seen just an explosion
there we've seen institutional investors
dive into the market there was a lot
going on during the pandemic housing
boom and you know part of that is there
was so much liquidity out there and they
wanted to grab up a lot of this run up
and home prices but also you know when
mortgage rates go down to two you know
two three percent the the and that moves
the payments down there's a a lot of
cash flow in these properties and a lot
more properties cash flow and are just
enticing to investors and they can
refinance their other homes and then
take on more properties so there was a
huge run up in investor activity during
the low mortgage rates of the pandemic
housing boom but we've seen that since
come back down and we've especially seen
a pullback in the bigger buyers the
bigger top dogs pulling back uh of their
home purchases right now
and and uh and you know and flippers
right now this is a very hard time to be
a flipper especially as we have those
Market Corrections out west
what about the geographies of Austin and
Miami actually as I'm thinking about
this we've talked a lot about you know
San Francisco New York and in those
areas one of the narratives whether you
know accurate or not is that lots of
people were fleeing the San Francisco's
and New Yorks and they were moving to
the Texas and Florida markets there's a
report I think that came out at the
either December or January from Goldman
Sachs that all of the folks in Miami
were running around and celebrating
saying hey every other housing market in
America is going to go down except for
Miami according to Goldman Sachs how do
you look at these markets that were you
know I would characterize as winners
from the pandemic migration do they
still have pretty healthy you know data
and entailments to them or should we
expect some sort of cooling off there
based on you know the various people you
see reporting on this yeah so what we've
seen is that the high cost markets out
west the LA's the Seattles the San
Francisco's have went into Market
Corrections price wise as soon as more
trade spiked and the feeder cities from
them Colorado Springs
Austin Phoenix Boise all of those places
have also had Corrections you go east
the high cost markets on the East have
not seen it the New Yorks right DC's as
much although a little more in DC and a
little more in Boston but still nothing
like out west and then Miami has not
either really and it you know there has
been a little bit you know but nothing
crazy and so we've seen a lot more
resiliency on the Eastern side of the
country than the western side of the
country why is that we're still trying
to actually figure it out uh because
they're you know Miami is very expensive
relative to incomes right now
um and so is Tampa and a lot of the
Southeastern markets but a part of the
reason that they might be more resilient
than the places like Phoenix and Boise
and in particular for Miami it is you
have a lot more cash buyers right coming
in especially from like Latin America
and these other places abroad and they
don't really give a [__] about where
mortgage rates are because they're a
cash buyer
um and so there's less of a rate
sensitivity for them and also you know
the elephant in the room is Tech uh out
west you know the the tech Market just
dominates and we've seen a huge pullback
and the equities for tech stocks
especially for a lot of the Unicorn
types
um that were you know leading a lot of
their you know employees to go out and
buy homes as they got closer to IPO and
they had the huge run-ups and we saw a
lot of that during the pandemic uh so I
think some of its job market and then
some of it's also resiliency of demand
yeah it's fascinating to think about
um the cash buyers and kind of the
impact they can have in our Market
because they don't care about the
mortgage rates um are there other
markets outside of Miami which you know
the joke uh is that Miami is the capital
of Latin America but like are there
other markets where there's a lot of
cash buyers and we see a similar dynamic
you know when I look at the United
States uh and you know there's not
really a U.S housing market there is and
there isn't uh but you know as you kind
of break it up you can kind of group
places a few of the places that you
can't really group or like New York it's
like its own thing it's a very weird uh
interesting Market San Francisco is one
of those places and I also think that
Miami is as well
um and you know it's a very unique
Market
um
you know it it and you know another
factor for Miami Take Miami and Austin
both markets saw a huge drawl during the
pandemic
but Miami there's not as much home
construction relative to Austin which
has all of the space outside of the city
and so as Austin started to boom during
the pandemic Builders really ramped up
in the Austin metropolitan area and so
now once mortgage rates spiked and the
demand for those new homes slowed
inventory built up much much faster in
Austin I think inventory year over year
is up like 200 percent in Austin and
from the bottom I think it's like three
or four hundred percent and so it's just
a different Market than Miami yeah and
Miami just has more resiliency right now
yeah that's crazy
um when you wake up in the morning what
data points do you look at to evaluate
how housing's doing like are there one
or two data points you're like these are
the ones that I I put the most weight on
yeah every day when I wake up and I
check the financial markets I go look at
the 10-year yield because mortgage rates
although you know they don't you know
the the spread between them kind of
fluctuated and has actually gotten
bigger during the pandemic they move in
sync right so if the 10-year yield goes
up usually mortgage rates are going to
go with it and so I'm looking at that
every day because mortgage rates are the
most important factor right now for the
housing market that uh that makes a ton
of sense Lance I could talk to you all
day about this stuff it uh is somewhat
of a nuanced conversation around
financial data but
um I think it really is a huge story uh
in terms of what's Happening across
financial markets where can we send
people to find you on the Internet to
read the articles that you're putting
out for fortune or follow along with
your tweets yeah and I you know I really
appreciate you having me on uh you know
I think you do a lot of great stuff uh
and you can find me by Googling Lance
Lambert Fortune you'll find my author
page and you can also find me on Twitter
at news Lambert awesome Lance thank you
so much we definitely will do this again
in the future hopefully next time we
talk the housing market will be booming
everyone will be getting rich and we
won't have so much bad news but uh I
appreciate uh your attention to detail
and the various articles you write I
highly suggest anyone uh who has not
read your stuff to go do so and then
you're a great follow on Twitter uh so
recommend doing that as well we will uh
we'll definitely talk again in the
future
appreciate it housing housing housing